good morning believe nation today's
message is do you really want it over to
you george RR martin ask yourself what
if no one ever bought any of my work
what if I'm never gonna sell a book or
publish a book or a short story are you
gonna continue to write and if the
answer is yes because I have to do then
yeah then you are a writer and whether
you're selling out I can't no but if
they're stories and you that have to get
out and want to put them down in the
paper with it whether you ever get the
affirmation of a contract or a book in
your hand or being on the bestseller
list if you still have to tell your
stories then then your writer if you can
give it up then then it probably would
be an act of sanity to learn accounting
or something like that
I think this lesson applies to everybody
in the early stages of entrepreneurship
whether you want to be a writer whether
you want to be a musician whether you
want to be an actor whether you want to
be an innovator whether you want to be a
youtuber whether you want to make chairs
whether you want to be a dancer whatever
it is whatever it is expect little to no
traction at the beginning when I first
started my entrepreneurship career my
first business in the biotech software
company I was making $300 a month we had
zero traction built up and I just I
could not live with the idea of not
knowing and so even though I had these
high-paying jobs available to me I had
to say no I'm putting that on hold
because I need to try this out I'm okay
with it not working but I'm not okay
with not knowing I had to give it a shot
so we kept going and ended up working
out for my first kind of speaking gig
being an entrepreneur an expert and
giving some advice to people the first
event was for it was free and had three
people show up at my local YMCA three
people and I put all of this work and
energy and love into making it happen
and only three people showed up and my
heart sank walking into that room and
seeing nobody show up for a free thing
and logically you're thinking if only
three people show up to your first
free event how are you ever gonna charge
for this right how is this ever gonna be
a business and for me I didn't care I
didn't care if it even
ever became a business I loved it I
loved helping those three people out and
then with time' grew three became five
became eight became twenty became thirty
you know just kept growing up to then
starting on the youtube channel when I
started on the YouTube channel I had no
results go back and look at my first
videos no comments
little views I just liked the process of
doing it and I think that's what's so
important you have to not be just
attached to the goal of something
working out you have to be attached to
the process of doing the work if you
really really really really really want
to do it then you'll find time to go out
and do it and that's a trait that you'll
find in all successful entrepreneurs you
have some early failures at the start
and you keep going where most people
quit where it's the logical thing to
quit
where it's the same thing to quit where
the brain says quit this is not working
stop doing it and something makes you
want to keep going that's when you know
you're on the right path so the question
today today is I'm curious what have you
had to give up to be the entrepreneur
what opportunities did you give what
what opportunity to give up on what
things that you pass by on because you
said no I'm gonna focus on this I'm
gonna try to make this thing work I'm
gonna give this my all what did you give
up to get here leave it in the comments
below super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to thong
Union thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book it really really really
means a lot to me so thank you guys for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go